In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 9, on which we commemorate our Holy Father,
Cyril, patriarch of Alexandria.
On the 9th of the month we celebrate the memory of our Holy Father, the God-bearer, Cyril,
archbishop of Alexandria.
The St. Athanasius, who was the adamant defender of the Homousios, consubstantial.
The Church of Alexandria was, for the whole world, the lighthouse of Orthodoxy, thanks to
St. Cyril, the champion of the Thilthocles, the mother of God, the touchstone of the dogma
of the incarnation.
Born in about 360, he was early placed under the protection of his uncle, Philphilus, archbishop
of Alexandria, who gave him a complete formation in rhetoric and philosophy, and especially
in the Holy Scriptures, which he knew almost by heart, and was able to put to good use.
Placing his great learning at the service of the Church, the young Cyril was included
among the clergy and called to succeed the Philphilus.
He accompanied him to Constantinople and was present at the Iniquities Pirate Council of
the Oak in 403, which unjustly condemned St. John Chrysostom.
He later refused for a long time to write St. John's name on the diptych's, more from
devotion to his uncle's memory than from doctrinal opposition to the Holy Hierarch, and it was
only on the urging of St. Isador of Palusium, and it is said after a vision of the mother
of God with St. John Chrysostom beside her that he consented to put it in again, and
even became a fervent supporter of his veneration in 417.
On Philphilus's death in 412, he was immediately consecrated archbishop of Alexandria, despite
violent opposition from the supporters of Archdecan Timothy, of an energetic character
and gifted with ardent zeal for the defense of the truth.
St. Cyril undertook to strengthen the unity of the Church, which was at the time in full
flower, but was still threatened by various divisive elements.
Preaching to his people the love of the true faith which had been preserved by the Holy
Fathers through so many battles against the heretics, he took authoritative measures
against the novation schismatics, who were drawing many of the orthodox to their side
because of their austerity and moral rigor.
He had their churches closed and forbade their bishop to fulfill his functions.
To combat the remains of paganism and the superstitions which still gripped the people,
he had the relics of St. Cyrus and John translated from Alexandria to Manuthus near Canope.
Famous for its diabolically-inspired oracles and himself took the head of the procession
which lasted a whole week.
Although Alexandria was a Christian city, it still had an important Jewish colony, which
often disturbed the peace with riots and attacks on the Christians.
Following one of these incidents, the bishop summoned the heads of the Jewish community
and reprimanded them with threats.
They in revenge, pretending there was a fire in the Church of St. Alexander, brought the Christians
together at night and slew a great many of them.
In the face of the inertia of prefect arrestes, who, fearing the growing power of the bishop
in civil matters was predisposed to the Jews, St. Cyril had them all expelled from the city
and turned the synagogues into churches.
It was thus that the Jewish colony in Alexandria, which had been well known since the time of Alexander
the Great, came to an end.
But these events poisoned the archbishop's relations with the prefect.
Some monks from Nigeria devoted to St. Cyril placed themselves one day in the magistrate's
path and called him a pagan.
And one of them, Ammonius, grabbed a stone and threw it at his head.
He was at once arrested and tortured with such violence that he died.
Further disorder also followed the ignoble killing of Hepatia, a virtuous woman of great authority
in the realm of philosophy, who was venerated throughout the world.
She was murdered by an unruly group of Christian fanatics, who, suspecting that she was
acting as a go-between for the bishop and prefect arrestes, were intent on impending
their reconciliation.
In the midst of these troubles which spilled a great deal of blood, St. Cyril strove to have
justice respected and he finally achieved the recognition of the church's authority in
every aspect of city life.
Having inherited the famous school of Alexandria and having probably been a pupil of Dittimus
the blind, the holy bishop devoted a great deal of his time to the writing of exegetical
works with allegorical and moral commentaries on details of the Old Testament, in which
he discerned the mystery of Christ manifested in Enigma's.
It is this vision of the one Christ as the fulfillment of the law and the prophets that
was to direct the whole of his life, and divine providence was soon to require of him that
he applied both on the theological level and on that of ecclesiastical activity.
In 428 Constantinople applied to Antioch to have the priest Nestorius elevated to the patriarchal
C. He was known for his eloquence and for the austere life he purported to lead.
This election was greeted with great joy, not just by the people of the capital, who hoped
to receive in him a new Christom, but also by the worldwide episcopate, including St. Cyril.
However, as soon as he was consecrated, Nestorius cast off his mask of piety and revealed
an intemperate zeal in warring with the heretics, declaring himself ready to wreck all the towns
in order to drive them out.
He soon made himself heartily disliked by his violence and pride, and began to make
imprudent declarations concerning the incarnation, pushing the limit of the theological tradition
of the School of Antioch, which stressed the distinction in the Lord's actions between
those that revealed his divine nature and others that belonged to his human nature, Nestorius
undertook to give an abstract and rationalist explanation of the incarnation, without, however,
making use of adequate concepts to explain the way the natures were united.
Introducing a duality of agents between the Word of God and Christ the mere man, he asserted
that the characteristics of divine and human nature would have to be attributed to one or the
other.
He was led as a consequence to consider that the Word had only taken on humanity as a tent,
an instrument, and that the Virgin Mary was not the mother of God, Phil Tocos, a title that
the Church's tradition had long given her, but only mother of Christ, Christ Tocos, stating
that one could not say that God was born of the Virgin, but is only united with him who
was born and died.
He merely saw in Christ an exemplary man, a God-bearer, divinized in a special way by his virtues,
in whom God dwelt in a way similar to that in which he inspired the prophets and the saints,
and who was in no way the Theantropos, the God-man, who is for men the source of salvation,
of life, grace, and sanctification.
Without ever himself speaking of two persons in Christ, he never seized attacking the concept
of the Phil Tocos, and one of his disciples, Bishop Dorothils, even stated one day in a sermon
in the presence of Nestorius, if a man says that Mary is the Phil Tocos, led him be anathema.
This would have meant the anathematization of all the God-bearing fathers who had used
the term and the bishops the world over who confessed the divine motherhood.
Conformed of this nascent heresy, Cyril solemnly set forth in his Paschal homily the following
year, in 429, that the Virgin had truly given birth to the Son of God, made man, and that she
therefore must rightly be called the Theantocos.
He wrote Nestorius a letter of brotherly remonstrance, asking him to accept the title on which
the whole doctrine of our salvation in Christ rested.
Even in the face of Nestorius' haughty and disdainful refusal, who, turning the accusations
against the archbishop of Alexandria, spread columnlies about him and attempted to have him
formally denounced, Cyril resolved to take up arms in defense of the truth, and declared
himself ready to suffer anything, even to death, rather than abandon the faith.
He addressed the treaties on the true faith to Emperor Theodosius I, his wife and sisters,
and sent a dossier on Nestorius' errors to Pope Celestine.
The Pope convoked a council in Rome, which condemned the errors and charged the archbishop of Alexandria
with carrying out the sentence pronounced against the heretic, if he refused to retract with
in ten days, in 430.
In the meantime, Saint Cyril had summoned a synod of bishops of Egypt, which wrote an exposé
of Christological doctrine, followed by the twelve anathemas of Nestorius' propositions
that Cyril had addressed to the heretic in his third letter.
In these polemical writings against Nestorius, faithful to the holy writ on the word made flesh
and to the fathers of the council of Nicaea who had confessed that the same son of God remaining
in the bosom of the Father became man, died and rose again.
Saint Cyril underlined the unity of the mystery of Christ.
He strove to show that from the first moment of his conception, the Lord definitively united
human and divine nature, and he contemplates in this mysterious union, Hennoses, with no
conjunction, Sinaphia, as Nestorius asserted, the exchange of natural properties and unity
of action of the Savior, who has opened to men the possibility of true participation with God,
of deification, of which the Mother of God is the prototype and model.
The Lord having thus inaugurated a new mode of existence, divine and human together in his
body, the Church, it is from his flesh truly become the flesh of the Word that we are given
life.
The one Christ of Saint Cyril is then he of the Eucharist and of spiritual experience, which
at the cost of long and difficult controversies the Church was to define in the succeeding generations.
During this time, Nestorius, relying on imperial authority and his friends at court, attempted
to impose his ideas in the capital by means of threats, corruption, excommunication
and the persecution of any who dared to resist him.
The situation became such that the Orthodox clergy begged Thildosios to convoke an ecumenical
council to put an end to this universal scandal of the Bishop of Constantinople.
But by a skillful twist, it was the heretic who persuaded the sovereign to summon the council,
to take place in Ephesus at Pentecost the following year in 431, in order to charge Saint Cyril
with heresy for his anathemas.
Cyril and Nestorius, having arrived in Ephesus at the heads of imposing entorages, they
awaited the coming of Archbishop John of Antioch and the Eastern bishops, whom Nestorius
had won over to his cause.
This was not because of the rejection of the term Thildocos, but by his sending them Cyril's
anathemas, which they could only read out of context, as though they were a restoration
of the Apollonarius' heresy.
Finally, as they were late, it was decided to open the first session without the orientals
on the 22nd of June in 431.
Saint Cyril presided, standing in for the Pope of Rome, whose legates were also late.
After having had the Nicene Creed read, and then Cyril's letter to Nestorius, and the
letters reply, the fathers who numbered about 200 proclaimed the legitimacy of the term Thildocos,
and opposed Nestorius, who had three times refused to appear.
On leaving the church, they were welcomed with an ovation by a crowd devoted to the veneration
of the Mother of God, with women burning incense along their path.
Directly on the arrival in Ephesus of John of Antioch and his party, five days later, he
offended that they had not been waited for, convoked a council of 43 bishops, and accusing
Cyril of having revived the heresy of Apollonarius pronounced his deposition with no other formality
than the acquiescence of Memnon of Ephesus.
The ecumenical council thus found itself transformed into a violent and passionate battle between
two parties that were trying to get the Emperor's protection.
A luth and ill informed Thodosius, after feudal attempts at reconciliation, had Cyril and Memnon
arrested while declaring Nestorius a heretic, and ordered that the assembly be disbanded.
The only result of the council was that it set out the firm grounds for the term Thildocos,
and proceeded to the deposition of Nestorius, who was sent to his monastery in Antioch
and then exiled to Libya in 435, where he died a miserable death.
They found themselves nonetheless, faced with a new and cruel division, at the moment at
which the Empire, threatened by the barbarians, was a need of the greatest cohesion.
There could be seen only quarrels, mutual anathemas, and disorder, under the pretext of devotion
to the truth, that exposed the holiness of the Church to the mockery of its enemies.
During the laborious negotiations that followed, St. Cyril, who had returned to Alexandria where
the people gave him a triumphant welcome, showed not only his orthodoxy, but also his humility
and the abundance of his virtue, refusing to demand justice for the ill treatment he had
received in Ephesus during his imprisonment, he gave the orientals an explanation of the
anathemas that had offended them so deeply, and he stated that they were only against Nestorius'
heretical dogmas, also declaring that he was ready to correct them, on condition that John
and his party consented to Nestorius' condemnation.
They finally reached an agreement, and the orientals sent Cyril a confession of faith
that he welcomed with a jubilant letter.
In a spirit of peace, but without abandoning his fundamental thesis, he made judicious
concessions to Antioch's traditional terminology, and accepted the distinction that was made there
of the two natures united without confusion or co-mingling in the unique person of Jesus Christ.
This act of union created in April 433, although it was not a conciliar decision, is nevertheless
considered as the profession of faith of the third ecumenical counsel and the rule of orthodoxy.
It refuted in advance the heretical proposals of Yudikes and the monophysites, who claimed
that some of the writings of Saint Cyril supported their belief that the human nature of Christ
is, as though absorbed by the divinity and the counsel of Calcedon in 451, was only held
to reassert and precise its essential terms.
A fragile peace being established, Saint Cyril spent the last years of his episcopate in confirming
the unity of the Church and in moderating the excesses of his two zealous partisans, who accused
him of betraying their cause by the union with the orientals.
In Eward to strive by his experience of ecclesiastical affairs and human passions, he showed himself
in those circumstances a model of moderation and pastoral clemency.
In this way he refuted the writings of Theodore of Mopswesta, the great theologian of the School
of Antioch, who died in the peace of the Church in 428, but refused to demand his condemnation,
in order not to upset the sensibilities of the orientals again, and so put the unity
of the Church in danger.
Having finished the work that God had confided to him for the edification of his Church, Saint
Cyril fell asleep in peace on the 27th of June in 444, to join the choir of the Holy Fathers
and to take his seat together with Saint John Chrysostom alongside the Mother of God.
He was at once venerated as a saint and praised as the Enlightener of the world, the Invincible
Defender of Orthodoxy and the Seal of the Fathers.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.